[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen in allen Katja Stresow ist
auch dabei für den Sport hallo und guten
Abend und das sind die Nachrichtenthemen
von heute
Russland macht mobil Präsident Putin
ruft für den ukrainekrieg 300.000
Reservisten zu den Waffen für
Bundeskanzler Scholz ein Akt der
Verzweiflung
die gasumlage bleibt vorerst hält die
Bundesregierung an dem Kostenaufschlag
Fest trotz der Verstaatlichung des
versorgungsriesen Juniper
und Corona sorgen im Team
fußball-bundestrainer fliegt muss in den
kommenden zwei Spielen auf Leon Goretzka
und Manuel Neuer verzichten
[Musik]
die Ukraine hat in den vergangenen
Wochen hunderte von russisch besetzten
Städten und Dörfern zurückerobert heute
nun die Antwort aus Moskau der russische
Präsident kündigt eine Teilmobilmachung
an 300.000 Reservisten dürfen Russland
nicht mehr verlassen sie sollen in den
Krieg in die Ukraine ziehen zudem droht
Putin indirekt mit dem Einsatz von
Atomwaffen Sebastian eben berichtet
in den russischen Nachrichtensendungen
gibt es heute nur ein Thema die
Fernsehansprache von Präsident Wladimir
Putin die Botschaft die der Kreml heute
an sein Volk sendet ist ein Paukenschlag
und wird das Leben zehntausender Russen
verändern wir wollen die Sicherheit
unserer Bevölkerung und der in den
befreiten Gebieten gewährleisten
deswegen halte ich es für notwendig den
Vorschlag unseres
Verteidigungsministeriums und der
Generäle zur unterstützen und eine
Teilmobilmachung in der Russischen
Föderation einzuleiten
[Musik]
einen entsprechenden Erlass habe er
bereits unterzeichnet dieser trete heute
in Kraft gegen die Bekanntmachung
formiert sich Protest in Russland hier
in Nowosibirsk gehen die Menschen auf
die Straße bis die Polizei rigoros
einschreitet es gibt Festnahmen ähnliche
Bilder in Tomsk und Jekaterinenburg in
Moskau selbst ist die Meinung am Morgen
geteilt
ich habe fünf Söhne ich möchte nicht
dass sie in den Krieg gehen
augenscheinlich reichen die Ressourcen
nicht aus es werden Leute gebraucht die
müssen das ja irgendwie beenden
in diesen von Russland besetzten
Gebieten sollen ab Freitag
Volksabstimmungen über einen Anschluss
an Russland abgehalten werden dass dort
freie Willensbildung und faire
Abstimmungen möglich sein werden gilt
als ausgeschlossen und genau dort sowie
an der 1.000 Kilometer langen Front
sollen auch die einberufenen Reservisten
zum Einsatz kommen wie so häufig drohte
Vladimir Putin heute in seiner Ansprache
auch dem Westen
die russischen Bürger können sich sicher
sein dass die territoriale Integrität
unseres Heimatlandes gesichert und
unsere Unabhängigkeit und Freiheit
gewährleistet ist das will ich noch
einmal betonen und zwar mit all den uns
zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln
diejenigen die versuchen uns mit
Nuklearwaffen zu erpressen sollten
wissen der Wind kann sich schnell drehen
aktuelle Bilder von der Finish
russischen Grenze zeigen lange Staus bei
der Ausreise und zur Stunde diese
Aufnahmen aus Moskau Protest auch in der
Hauptstadt und auch hier schreitet die
Polizei sofort ein
und genau dort im Zentrum moskau ist
Christian sem was passiert da gerade
ja ich stehe hier am alten Arbeit das
ist eine berühmte Touristenstraße mitten
in Moskau und hier war vor einer Stunde
ein Protestmarsch geplant zum
nahegelegenen Außenministerium wir haben
uns hier versammelt auch sehr viele
Presse ist wirkt alles zunächst recht
ruhig doch dann ist die Polizei massiv
zwischen die Demonstranten gegangen es
gab die ersten Festnahmen die Menschen
haben sich lautstark beschwert wir haben
viele Frauen gesehen die vor
Verzweiflung geweint haben und die
Polizei ist hier wirklich radikal
dazwischen gegangen und nimmt jetzt
immer noch Menschen fest wir können das
hier sehen hier stehen immer noch die
Gefangenentransporte in die die
Demonstranten gebracht werden also der
Staat zeigt knallhart dass er sich hier
keinen Protest wünscht das Protest nicht
geduldet wird und wir haben in den
letzten Jahren ja hier immer wieder
Demonstrationen Demonstrationen
begleitet bei denen es auch Festnahmen
gegeben hat und so brutal wie heute habe
ich es noch nicht gesehen
danke nach Moskau für diese
Informationen Christian Semm war das
eine weitere Eskalation des Krieges so
wertet Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg
die Teilmobilmachung das zeige dass der
Krieg nicht so verlaufe wie Putin sich
das vorgestellt hat auch der
US-Präsident und der Bundeskanzler
kritisierten den Schritt Putins scharf
beide Sprachen vor der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen in New York von dort berichtet
Johannes Hano
der Bundeskanzler heute Morgen auf dem
Weg zu einem Interview mit der New York
Times gestern schon war durchgesickert
dass der russische Präsident eine
Videobotschaft aufgezeichnet hatte die
Ankündigung einer teilmobil-machung dann
heute morgen keine echte Überraschung
die jüngsten Entscheidungen der
russischen Regierung sind ein Akt der
Verzweiflung Russland kann diesen
verbrecherischen Krieg nicht gewinnen
und mit den jüngsten Entscheidungen
macht Putin macht Russland das alles nur
noch viel schlimmer gestern Abend schon
bei der ersten Rede eines deutschen
Bundeskanzlers bei der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen seit 15 Jahren hat Olaf Scholz
klar gemacht dass man sich russischem
Druck nicht beugen werde viel zu viel
stehe auf dem Spiel Selbstbestimmung und
politische Unabhängigkeit zählen für ihn
nicht das ist blanker Imperialismus
die Rückkehr des Imperialismus ist nicht
nur ein Desaster für Europa
darin liegt ein Desaster auch für unsere
globale Friedensordnung die die
Antithese ist zu Imperialismus und
Neokolonialismus heute Vormittag sprach
dann auch der US-Präsident vor der
Weltgemeinschaft und auch er machte klar
dass die neue russische Eskalation die
USA von ihrem Kurs nicht abbringen
werden
Ukraine hat das gleiche Recht wie jedes
souveräne Land wir stehen in Solidarität
mit der Ukraine wir stehen in
Solidarität gegen die russische
Aggression Punkt
am Rande der Generalversammlung äußerte
sich auch der Nato-Generalsekretär zu
Putins Plänen
bisher sehen wir keine Veränderungen
Russlands Bereitschaft Nuklearwaffen
einzusetzen aber wir beobachten das
genau und bleiben wachsam
eines aber ist klar Putins Rede wird
hier bei den Vereinten Nationen als
weitere Eskalation gesehen
ja Johannes Hano in New York wie gehen
die Staaten mit Putins Rede um gibt es
da jetzt mehr Einigkeit
also Putins Ankündigungen und dunkle
Drohungen die haben hier werden hier
wahrgenommen und werden auch sehr ernst
genommen aber wenn man sich hier so
umhört dann kriegt man mit das Putin
sich damit hier weiter isoliert hat
selbst Länder die bislang sehr eng mit
Russland zusammengearbeitet haben wie
ich China machen deutlich dass Sie nicht
bereit sind zu einer weiteren Eskalation
es wird gesagt Putin sollte sich jetzt
endlich an den Tisch setzen und
verhandeln und der US-Präsident hat die
Gelegenheit hier vorhin genutzt um der
Weltöffentlichkeit noch mal klar zu
machen und was für ein Staat es sich bei
Russland im Moment handelt ein
Gründungsmitglied der Vereinten Nationen
dass sich dazu erklärt hat Frieden und
die Sicherheit in der Welt zu warn droht
jetzt möglicherweise mit atomschlägen in
Europa ein solches Land müsse geächtet
werden weil es die Karte der Vereinten
Nationen verachte und so könnte man
nicht weitermachen ganz klar russland
hat sich hier keine neuen Freunde
gemacht Johannes Hanau war das live aus
New York vielen Dank
die Teilmobilmachung Moskaus ist Thema
in einem zdf-spezialdirekt nach uns und
ZDF heute live spricht mit zwei Experten
über Putins Pläne ab 19.45 auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen und in der App
ein Ziel hat Putin erreicht das fehlende
Gas aus Russland setzt Deutschland unter
Druck um die Energieversorgung zu
sichern wird deutschlands größter
gasimporteur Juniper verstaatlicht das
kündigte am Morgen Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck an warum Unternehmen wie Juniper
für die deutsche Gasversorgung so
wichtig sind erklärt Christoph desterell
fast jede zweite Heizung in Deutschland
läuft mit Gas das bekommen die Kunden
von den Stadtwerken oder anderen
Anbietern die wiederum bestellen Ihren
Bedarf ebenso wie die Wirtschaft über
langfristige Verträge bei den großen
Drei Juniper safe energy jemals Gazprom
Germania und VNG auch sie haben
eigentlich langfristige Verträge mit
ihrem Hauptlieferanten Russland der
liefert aber fast nichts mehr Juniper
und Co mussten zuletzt also teures
ersatzgas einkaufen und es wie zugesagt
viel billiger weitergeben
allein Juniper hat so im ersten Quartal
mehr als 12 Milliarden Verlust gemacht
ginge das Unternehmen pleite würde das
in Deutschland zu gasmangel oder extrem
Preisen führen Privatkunden überfordern
Firmen in Schleudern bringen
die Regierung kann also gar nicht anders
muss die großen Drei irgendwie
durchbringen mit dem Geld von Millionen
Gaskunden über die gasumlage die
Verbraucher ab Oktober Zahlen werden 34
Milliarden soll das bringen wobei
inzwischen klar ist das reicht nicht
also auch über Steuergelder mit denen
wird uniper jetzt verstaatlicht bei
sifferenergy und VNG könnte es früher
oder später ähnlich enden
Juniper wird also mit Milliarden von
Steuergeldern verstaatlicht warum müssen
Gaskunden dann überhaupt noch zusätzlich
eine Umlage Zahlen Fragen heute nicht
nur Verbraucherschützer auch
Wirtschaftsverbände fordern die
gasumlage muss vom Tisch und selbst
innerhalb der Koalition gibt es Streit
der Wirtschaftsminister und die SPD
wollen die Umlage rechtlich prüfen
lassen der Finanzminister nicht Patricia
Wiedemeyer
die Verluste waren jetzt einfach zu groß
bei uniper daher übernimmt der Bund 99%
der Aktien kauft den bisherigen
Anteilseigner Forum seine Anteile ab
erhöht das Kapital löst Kredite ab
Gesamtsumme etwa 30 Milliarden da aus
Russland kein Gas mehr kommt musste
gehandelt werden so Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck heute morgen die Probleme haben
sich noch einmal dramatisch verschärft
Juniper hat einen Anteil in ihrem
Portfolio von 50% aus russischem Gas und
steht für 40 Prozent der Deutschen
Gasversorgung etwa drei Monate wird es
dauern bis alles abgewickelt ist wie es
mit der gasumlage weitergeht offen ob
sie auch verfassungskonform ist wenn
Juniper verstaatlicht ist fraglich es
gibt inzwischen namhafte Juristen die
diese Zweifel angemeldet haben auch der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister selbst wir
brauchen in diesen Zeiten aber eine
Rechtssicherheit auch was die Einnahmen
betrifft am Nachmittag dann heftiger
Schlagabtausch im Bundestag zwischen
Regierung und Opposition um die
gasumlage
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zahlen gerade
ab dem 1 oktober in zehn Tagen eine
Umlage bei der wir da klar ist wer wofür
für wen zahlt und ob sie überhaupt kommt
und das ist chaospur in was hören wir
von der Opposition und das ist der
eigentliche Punkt die Gasanlage muss weg
sind wir denn hier im Fußballstadion
oder was ist das mit Demo muss weg sie
sind die muss weg auf Position was ist
denn das für eine Antwort die Union will
morgen einen Antrag stellen um die
gasumlage zu verhindern aber noch hält
die Regierung daran fest für die
Verbraucher heißt das sie müssen erst
einmal zahlen und zwar ab dem 1 Oktober
wie lange die gasumlage dann gilt ob
länger als drei Monate auch nach der
Verstaatlichung von Juniper das ist
derzeit noch offen genauso wie die Frage
ob die Umlage vielleicht noch teurer
wird auch das wurde hier heute in Berlin
nicht mehr ausgeschlossen
unklar bleibt auch wie der Bund mit
Junipers Beteiligungen an schwedischen
Kernkraftwerken und an der
Stromerzeugung in Russland umgehen will
viele offene Fragen
betroffen von der Energiekrise sind auch
die rund 1.000 Stadtwerke in Deutschland
Stadtwerke sind in der Regel kommunale
Unternehmen verantwortlich für Strom
Wasser und Gasversorgung die
explodierenden Preise bringen die
Stadtwerke und ihre Kunden in die
Bredouille Thomas Bersch
das ist seine Gasrechnung steigen würde
hatte rainer Schmidt aus Mülheim am Main
schon erwartet nicht aber dass sie sich
vervielfachen sollte
167 Euro zahlte er bis jetzt jeden Monat
825 sollen es fortan sein das heißt es
sind rund 500 Prozent mehr ich befürchte
dass viele Bürger in diesem Land nicht
in der Lage sind diesen Gaspreis zu
bezahlen bei den Stadtwerken bundesweit
mehren sich tatsächlich jetzt schon die
Anrufe in den Callcentern
wir sehen schon sehr besorgte Kunden wir
warnen vor und bitten darum auch schon
mal ein Stück weit Vorsorge zu treffen
finanzieller Art das macht die Menschen
auch
nervös und wenn Kunden sich nervös
zeigen überträgt sich das nahtlos auf
die Stadtwerke selbst wohl jeder hier
beim Kongress kommunaler Versorger heute
in Leipzig rechnet mit Kunden die ihre
Zahlungen bald nicht mehr leisten können
die Frage ist nur wie viele werden das
sein und wie viele sind zu verkraften
tatsächlich wäre so etwas wie 10%
Zahlungsausfall etwas was selbst das
gesündeste Kommunalunternehmen ganz
schön unter Druck setzen könnte oder gar
in die das Risiko einer Insolvenz
ausgesetzt wird da müssen Bund da müssen
aber auch die Länder natürlich gemeinsam
bereit stehen und jetzt diesen
Schutzschirm zu gewähren noch liefern
zwar viele Stadtwerke das günstige Gas
der vor Krisenzeit doch so wird es nicht
bleiben ihr Ruf nach einem
Rettungsschirm oder einer Preisbremse er
wird nicht verstummen
die organisierte Kriminalität in
Deutschland ist auf dem Vormarsch mit
Drogenhandel Wirtschaftsdelikten und
Einbrüchen das zeigt ein Lagebild des
Bundeskriminalamts das Innenministerin
faesar heute vorstellte der
wirtschaftliche Schaden hat sich zuletzt
mehr als verdoppelt erstieg von 837
Millionen EURO 2020 auf 2,2 Milliarden
Euro im vergangenen Jahr außerdem sind
die Täter immer häufiger bewaffnet und
gehen mit immer größerer Brutalität vor
juristischer Paukenschlag in den USA
Donald Trump und drei seiner Kinder
stehen unter Anklage die
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft New York wirft
ihnen Betrug vor sie sollen
Vermögenswerte von
Immobiliengesellschaften falsch bewertet
haben es droht eine dreistellige
Millionenstrafe und ein geschäftsverbot
für den Staat New York Trumps Anwältin
wirft den Anklägern Amtsmissbrauch vor
die wütenden Proteste in Iran nach dem
Tod einer jungen Frau reißen nicht ab
mindestens sechs Menschen kamen dabei
ums Leben in verschiedenen Städten
werden auf den Straßen demonstrativ
Kopftücher verbrannt auch Bilder
religiöser Führer gehen in Flammen auf
auslöser war der Tod der 22-jährigen
Mascha armini sie war von der
Sittenpolizei festgenommen worden weil
sie in deren Augen ihr Kopftuch nicht
angemessen trug kurz darauf starb sie
unter ungeklärten Umständen
seit dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine steht auch die internationale
Zusammenarbeit im Weltraum auf der Kippe
in Zeiten schwerster Spannungen
starteten heute zwei russische
Kosmonauten und ein us-astronaut
gemeinsam zur Internationalen
Raumstation isss das sei jus-raumschiff
ob am Abend vom Weltraumbahnhof bei
kumur in Kasachstan ab
könnte so einfach sein und abgereist
sind drei Spieler der
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft ja zwei Tage
vor dem nations League Spiel gegen
Ungarn wurden Torhüter Manuel Neuer und
Mittelfeldspieler Leon Goretzka Corona
positiv getestet sie verließen das
Trainingslager in Gravenbruch bei
Frankfurt genauso wie offensiv man
Julian Brandt er allerdings nur mit
grippalem Infekt
corona-schock und Personal sorgen stören
die Vorbereitung Leon Goretzka am
Lenkrad und Manuel Neuer als Beifahrer
verlassen am Nachmittag das Quartier
beide sind symptomfrei wurden aber
umgehend isoliert ihre Kontaktperson
soll nun täglich getestet werden somit
sind weitere Ausfälle zu befürchten für
Goretzka und in krippekranken Brand
wurde Maximilian Arnold nachnominiert
für neuer wird Oliver Baumann anreisen
längere Zeit kein Thema war aber auch so
ein bisschen absehbar das natürlich
Richtung Herbst wahrscheinlich das ganze
schon wieder auf uns zukommt jetzt gilt
es halt mit den Spielern die
bereit sind dann auch die Spiele
bestmöglich zu bestreiten aufgrund der
Ausfälle muss Flick umplanen für neuer
wird entweder Kevin Trapp oder Marc
André ter Stegen spielen wenn sie denn
gesund bleiben
Blech statt Titelverteidigung so kann
man das Mix Zeitfahren bei der
Straßenrad WM na Sidney in Australien wo
am schnellsten zusammenfassen die
deutsche Mannschaft aus drei Frauen und
drei Männern wurde Vierte mit sieben
Sekunden Rückstand auf Rang 3 den Kampf
um Bronze müssen die beiden verbliebenen
von drei Frauen des Mixed-Teams aufgeben
als Mike Kröger das hohe Tempo ihrer
Kollege nicht mehr mitgehen kann Liane
Lippert muss warten weil sie gemeinsam
mit bahnrad-weltmeisterin Kröger ins
Ziel kommen muss so wird es Rang 4
hinter dem Team Australiens Gold geht an
die Schweiz Silber an Italien das
deutsche Team kann den Titel des
vergangenen Jahres ohne die
zurückgetretenen Lisa brennnauer und
Tony Martin nicht verteidigen die
Niederlande trifft es besonders hart
erst hat Bauke mollemar einen
technischen Defekt dann kommt auch noch
Annemie von flirten zu Sturz die
Favoriten auf Gold landen letztlich auf
Rang 5
aber immerhin gab es Medaillen bei der
U23 und den Juniorinnen für Deutschland
ich habe immer noch den Sturz im Kopf
alles glimpflich fehlen noch wie jeden
Mittwoch die Lottozahlen
sie lauten sieben acht 24 30 36 48 und
die Superzahl 8 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im
zdf-text auf Seite 557
das ruhige Hochdruckwetter setzt sich
auch morgen fort die Details hat gleich
östenthali im heute-journal um kurz vor
10 spricht Marietta Slomka mit
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg wir
danken für Ihr Interesse wünschen Ihnen
alles Gute und sind morgen wieder da
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter das hoch über
Mitteleuropa verdrängt allmählich die
Schauer dafür gibt es allerdings dann
Nebel in der Nacht und von Südwesten
kommt warme Luft vor allem in die
westlichen Landesteile in der Nacht also
Richtung Schleswig-Holstein Nebel auch
in den östlichen Landesteilen sowie
Richtung Donau im Südwesten klart es auf
Temperaturen gehen zurück bis auf -1°
frostigkeit am Alpenrand oder null Grad
im hessischen Bergland 10 Grad am
mildesten an der Nordsee morgen gibt es
viel Sonnenschein nach Nebelauflösung
kompakte Wolken in der Mitte aber da
fällt nichts heraus und die Temperaturen
höchste Werte 14 Grad im Vogtland und 20
Grad zum Beispiel am Niederrhein am
Freitag noch mal trocken bis 22 Grad am
Samstag kommen neue schaue ins lands
einen schönen Abend